hey if you want to get some epic anime
merch that you're not gonna find
anywhere else check out our online store
anime out Broadcom we have esken or
praise the Sun Mele Otis feel the wrath
bond love the pain more esken or more
Mele Otis and other things too so check
us out link in the description hey what
is up everybody its Anna Mac here for
anime uproar and today I will be delving
deep into the most recent 7 Deadly Sins
developments including the raging battle
against the demon king at full strength
and also the burning questions about
Eskin or and what is really happening
with him his body and sunshine get it
burning questions anyway there is a lot
to cover in today's video
the fate of Eskin or and by extension
the rest of the seven deadly sins is on
the line so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the seven deadly sins
content on this channel please leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest seven
deadly sins news and updates and of
course this video will contain manga
spoilers we are talking about the latest
developments in the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned back in Chapter three two one we
saw esker make his epic entrance as he
blocked off the demon King's sword with
his bare hands and joined the rest of
the sins of Elizabeth on the battlefield
in chapter 3 to 2 in quintessential
esken or fashion the master of the Sun
decides that after blocking the demon
King's sword he should recite a poem in
the poem which I dare not repeat myself
because I am not worthy of Lord s
canora's words asking her praises the
seven deadly sins their courage and
their commitment to each other s kannur
also pledges to put his life on the line
for his friends the seven deadly sins
and by standing up to the demon king so
directly he demonstrates his boldness
and courage miele who had just given
sunshine back to us Canora a short while
ago watches the battlefield from up
above and he says there's nothing I can
do against a monster like him referring
of course to the demon king to be honest
I am
really disappointed with my L and how
his character has been used or rather
completely underused in this arc d esta
rosa / mile arc was absolutely amazing
and esta rosa is probably my favorite
villain in the entire series after Maya
regained his memories and then after he
regained sunshine and one shot at the
original demon I was expecting to see a
lot more from Maya does mile also have
at the one mode like a scan or and if he
does is his the one mode even stronger
to ask ignores because mile is a goddess
and Eskin or is just a human these are
the questions that I wanted to see
explored in this current arc and in the
fight against the demon king but it
looks like we won't get to see any of
that sin smile is apparently scared to
even help the sins fight against the
demon king this is pretty ridiculous to
be honest I get that a plot required for
Eskin or to get sunshine back but I
still wanted to see my I'll play a
bigger role
maybe if mild tried fighting the demon
king failed and then gave sunshine back
to ask her because he was no longer able
to fight I would understand but having
my I'll act like a complete coward when
we know how strong he is and what we
know all the feeds that he was able to
accomplish in the past just doesn't sit
right with me at all let me know if you
agree or disagree with me on my el down
in the comments but back to the main
fight where meliodas calls out to ask an
or and warns him that if he continues
using this form his overpowered daytime
form he knows what's going to happen we
can assume the Malloys is talking about
the fact that s canora's human body is
reaching its limit and if a second or
overexerts himself in this battle his
body could give out and he could
actually die the demon king then lands a
nice shot on esken or and he is also
able to slash Eskin or with his sword
but he can't take s Kannur down and s
Kannur is able to fight back using his
divine spear s can or and divine sword s
Kannur which are basically just an epic
finger poke and an overpowered karate
chop however looking at s Connors body
after this exchange it is clear that the
demon king was able to do real damage to
s Kannur s can ors face is clearly
injured and his body is covered in
bloody slashes as old p and confident as
Eska nor is these panels are clearly
intended to show us that s Kannur is not
invincible and that he is taking
damaged in this fight we know from what
he said before that he must be an
enormous pain but s kannur continues to
soldier on and he tells meliodas to go
and save zelgius before he accidentally
kills the demon king a classic esken or
flex right there naturally this
infuriates the demon king and he goes on
the attack once again but before the
demon king can land his blow bond and
king interfere and pushed a demon king
back Mele Otis thanks everyone for their
bravery and he proceeds to enter sell
dresses soul using golfers invasion
ability on the inside
manly Otis and Gotha find themselves in
a setting that looks exactly like the
place where meliodas and zelgius used to
hunt dragons when they were younger
Zell drous is clearly feeling a strong
sense of nostalgia for the time he had
spent with his brother in this place and
that is why this place was recreated by
his elders his consciousness I have a
feeling that this location is no
coincidence despite the fact that the
demon king in the form of the fake gelda
tried to convince ljus that meliodas
betrayed him and that he secretly killed
gelda it seems that zelda's his
consciousness or at least his sub
consciousness does not buy the demon
King's lies zelgius is subconsciousness
is saying that zelgius still has fond
memories of Mele otis and a deep inside
zelgius knows that malleolus would not
betray him in this way the fact that go
through malleolus have found themselves
in this specific place upon entering
Zell vs. soul is a clear hint that
zelgius is not fully gone and that there
is still hope for him to come to his
senses and resist the demon king at this
point go through Warren's meliodas that
they must not come into physical contact
with zell dress or the demon king wall
inside this inner world go thermally
Otis can only help zelgius with their
voices and their minds just like Golder
de sins and Elizabeth did for meliodas
back when he was being possessed by the
demon king in the end the only one who
will be able to fight against the demon
king on the inside is Zell drous himself
and this goes hand in hand with what I
just said I'm in at a goal Zell drous
will have to come to his senses and
resist the demon king willingly meliodas
and Gotha will not be able to do it for
him eventually go through millio to
spine Zell drous but he appears to be
unconscious and he has been restrained
by what looks like a giant sticky spider
web the fake gelda is there ready and
waiting as if she had been expecting
malleolus all along and
on fake galdós face just screams it's
about to go down brah it's about to go
down and as all of this is happening on
the inside the real gelda appears on the
outside hidden inside some sort of dark
circular orb probably because she is a
vampire and it is currently daytime so
she needs to protect herself
the real gelda appears just as the demon
king and s Canora are exchanging massive
blows and she comments that the two of
them have incredible magic and that they
are absolute monsters as she approaches
the battlefield gelda tastes some of the
blood that had been left on the ground
and she immediately recognizes that the
blood came from sell juices body
she says Zell I finally found you as
meliodas and Gotha prepared to face off
against the fake gelda on the inside and
that is how the chapter ends and we are
again left with a ton of anticipation
and excitement going into the next
chapter in my previous seven deadly sins
video I said that I believe that gelda
will appear on the battlefield at some
point in the near future and I was right
because she has indeed appeared at the
end of chapter 3 - - the only question
now is what role gelda will be able to
play obviously seeing the real Gale that
would instantly snap zelgius back into
reality and he would know without a
doubt that the gelda he has been talking
to his a fake and that malleolus did not
betray him but since malleolus and Gotha
have already entered Zelda's a soul I
don't know how gelda will be able to
make contact with Zell drous perhaps
vampires have the ability to enter
someone's mind as well since certain
types of psychic control are part of
vampire lore we'll have to wait and see
how it all goes down but I am definitely
curious about what is going to happen
next I am also very curious about ESCA
Noir and what is going to happen to him
it is clear that when he has sunshine s
canora's power reaches divine levels he
is able to go toe-to-toe with the demon
king at his strongest when even the
strongest of the four Archangels mile is
too scared to fight but s Canora is able
to fight and hold his own this suggests
that s Kannur with sunshine is not
necessarily weaker than mile with
sunshine I had always assumed that mile
with sunshine would be stronger for the
simple reason that his goddess body
should be much stronger than s Norse
human body so if my L without sunshine
is way stronger than s Kannur without
sunshine which is obviously the case
then it would make sense that mile with
sunshine would also be
chong'er than esken or with sunshine
nevertheless that doesn't seem to be the
case it looks like sunshine effects a
scan or differently than it affects my L
because I find it hard to believe the
mile would be too scared to fight the
demon king if sunshine had really made
him way stronger than s kannur with
sunshine if s candor can hold his own
against the demon king then
theoretically a much stronger mile would
have a clear advantage but that doesn't
seem to be the case so at this point we
have to assume that sunshine affects the
two men differently and so the power of
that base s Kannur gets from sunshine is
far greater than the power of that base
mile gets from the same power but
despite the fact that s kannur with
sunshine seems to be able to achieve
divine levels of power we also keep
getting reminded over and over again
that s kannur might be dying his human
body is not able to handle the power of
sunshine in perpetuity and both mile and
meliodas warned s Kannur that using
sunshine to fight a demon king could
lead to his death as this fight has
progressed we've definitely seen that s
Kannur is taking damage he might still
be confident he might still be standing
and he might still be fighting but he is
definitely not coming out of this duel
with the demon king unscathed even
though his power is enormous it seems
clear that s Kannur will not be able to
keep this up forever and in fact he may
be slowly dying as his body reaches its
limit s can or has vowed to keep the
demon king at bay for long enough for
meliodas to save zelgius but that
determination could also be a scores on
doing if he pushes himself too far to
the point of no return let me know what
you guys think why do you think that s
Canora appears to get a much bigger
power up from sunshine than mile and do
you think that s kern or is really going
to die or is this just more miss
direction from naka bouzouki let me know
down in the comments I love hearing from
you guys if you enjoyed this video you
want to see more you can leave a like to
let me know and if you're new to anime
uproar please don't forget to subscribe
and turn on all notifications that's the
only way that YouTube will actually
notify you follow me on twitter and
instagram at anime up lore for all the
latest news and updates on the seven
deadly sins i want to give a huge thank
you to all of our anime upper patrons
for supporting our work and making our
work possible a special thank you to all
of our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson Kings eldress and on
Kruse another massive thank you to our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all other clans including baby ray
ace
Ingrid ah al Olin Adam Maddy Mac
makoto-kun and Keylong and finally at
the very pinnacle of interdimensional
greatness a tier reserved only for
legends a massive thank you to Regan
Harrison and Lord naksan or disciples Oh
Lord to ego himself if you feel that our
content provides value for you when you
want to support more be sure to check
out our patreon link in the description
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]